all right so let's continue our
discussion of this Joe Biden Ukraine
conspiracy theory which is unfortunately
getting way more attention than it
deserves given that it is completely and
easily debunked particularly when the
real story here it's a serious real
story is that Donald Trump has made yet
another attempt to really atom and in
this case to collude with a foreign
power this time it's Ukraine Trump is
withholding hundreds of millions of
dollars in military aid if and until
such time as Ukraine smears Joe Biden in
order to help Trump win re-election in
2020 so Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump's
lawyer went on Fox News and usually when
I tell you that there was some kind of
pushback on Fox News or some counter
narrative or some grain of truth its
Shepard Smith or Chris Wallace or one
time Neil Cavuto this time it's actually
Fox News reporter John Roberts who I
think is formerly of CNN or maybe it was
CBS or ABC I don't remember in any case
John Roberts interviewed Rudy Giuliani
on Fox's Sunday program and to his
credit John Roberts not only did a
little devils advocate stuff with Rudy
where he said you know this doesn't look
appropriate for you to go to Ukraine
looking for dirt on Biden and getting
people to smear him John Roberts
actually holds firm and a little bit
presses Rudy Giuliani let's take a look
we're there to investigate alleged
Ukrainian interference in the 2006 TMJ
like you can't defend it alright so when
is morph into an investigation of Joe
Biden hunter Biden and is it appropriate
for you as a representative of the
President to be going to Ukraine and
finding dirt on Joe Biden and/or his son
to use politically in 2020 wait that's
the way you characterize it it's
certainly the way that's the way it
appears to line up no it doesn't you
went there for media lines it up this
began with someone coming to me saying
this information can clear your client
about the corruption in Ukraine between
the Ukraine the Democratic Party the
ambassador and the FBI agent who
investigated the days but it better than
it but that it won't send to Biden
inextricably combined because Biden had
the guy fired Shokan by the way his
statements on record the
press could go read it don't have to
listen to me there are three videotapes
of prosecutors on record available on
here so the immediate reaction is that
Fox News should be embarrassed merely to
have aired this and Giuliani shouldn't
even be allowed on these shows anymore
since all he does is lie but okay that
probably was not John Roberts call given
the expectations and the setting this
isn't bad but you know that you've
reached new lows in terms of what you're
doing and the absurdity of what you're
saying when you're a Republican and
during a Fox News interview you're
challenged and not just to get some
symbolic amount of disagreement on the
record but you get an actual challenge
at least to the extent that we would
expect to see on Fox News in a sense
it's relieving but it's also horrifying
because it's hard to imagine things
getting so bad as a normal state of
affairs for the presidential
administration that even Fox News feels
obligated to push back against the
absolutely absurd
unbelievable claims and actions of Rudy
Giuliani now there's a fair criticism to
be made of John Roberts here and the
criticism is asking whether it's
appropriate for Rudy to do this doesn't
even remotely get to the heart of the
problem which is that this should be
criminal if it is not and if it's not
it's not criminal because American law
didn't even account for the possibility
of a president doing what Donald Trump
and Giuliani are doing for the benefit
of Donald Trump's re-election campaign
in 2020 threatening to do and then
actually withholding military aid to
Ukraine
if and until they smear Joe Biden is so
outside of what anyone imagined a
president might do that is renato
Mariotti
told us in his political piece over the
weekend it could actually be difficult
to get Trump on bribery or corruption
because this is so high level in terms
of the international nature of it that
American law may not even actually cover
what it is that has taken place here the
thing that I've been thinking about the
last couple of days is aside from
whether the Trump administration
calculated that copping to elements of
what is being alleged publicly may be
better than the full truth getting out
which we may never know consider how
many countries have had similar
conversations with Donald Trump that
we've simply not found out about right
who else is Donald Trump extorting
internationally implicitly or explicitly
that we haven't heard about and I think
the iceberg analogy works well here with
an iceberg 90% of it or some large
percentage is under the waterline you
only see the tip of the iceberg that's
where the phrase comes from in this
administration I can only be led to
believe by the actions of the
administration that the same iceberg
analogy applies in the interim at the
micro level okay it was good that John
Roberts asked at least a few pressing
questions to Rudy Giuliani